this new generation of personal
watercraft is something entirely
different it does more than skim the
surface this watercraft Dives underwater
and can remain submerged at a depth of
three feet or more for up to a minute it
also leaps into the air and rolls with
the waves
this watercraft is painted to look like
a vintage fighter jet and it rolls and
Dives like one in the water
a worker sprays a gel coat into a mold
for the main body this gel will become
the shiny surface of the completed
fiberglass part
once the gel coat is hardened a worker
brushes a vinyl Ester resin onto it this
resin is known for its water resistance
he switches from a brush to a roller as
he generously applies the resin to the
hardened gel coat
the crew then drapes what's called
chopped strand mat over the mold this
fabric is made of long strands of
fiberglass the binder in it dissolves on
contact with the resin causing the
fabric to soften to the Contours of the
mold after trimming the excess material
the crew completely saturates The Strand
mat with more resin rolling it on firmly
gets rid of air bubbles
the top half of the main body mold has
been lined the same way
[Music]
they now bolt a dorsal fin mold to the
back on the top half of the mold
[Music]
the crew now joins the two halves of the
mold
[Music]
as a crane lowers the top to the bottom
workers ensure they line up perfectly
and they lock these two main molds
together with bolts
a worker enters through the cockpit
opening to roll on more resin
[Music]
meanwhile another member of the crew
pulls two sheets of fiberglass fabric
onto a cutting machine
the top fabric is a strong tightly woven
fiberglass and the bottom one is the
chop strand mat
automated blades cut the fiberglass to
various shapes and dimensions each one
designed for a different part of the
diving vessel mold
these large rectangles will be used to
mold the sides of the watercraft
after folding up the pieces the worker
hands them over to the fiberglass
technician
the technician has just an hour to apply
the fiberglass before the recently
applied resin starts to harden
he builds up eight layers and completely
saturates each one with more resin
while the thicker fiberglass material
provides strength
the thinner chopped strand mat AIDS
adhesion and helps the Fabrics conform
to the mold
after a three hour cure workers have a
solid seamless fuselage
crane lifts the fuselage out of the mold
and moves it onto a dolly where it will
stay while the team works on the other
parts of the watercraft
[Music]
shaped front bumper is next
the worker uses only three layers of
fiberglass to make it because this
bumper is meant to collapse in the event
of a collision
for that reason the part is also known
as the vessel's sacrificial nose
[Music]
at another station crew members lined
fin shaped molds with fiberglass and
then pour liquefied plastic into the
cavity once cured the plastic will
anchor the top of a steel Wing shaft in
the fin a worker presses the shaft into
the liquefied plastic with the end
protruding from the fin
a second mold also lined with fiberglass
and filled with a plastic core goes on
top
the team bolts it together and leaves
the part to cure
the fins will ultimately be supported by
a triangular scaffold made of aluminum
square tubing the worker clamps the
scaffold framework to a work table to
stabilize the framework as he welds it
together he then welds the scaffold
Tower to the base
the worker drills holes for the bushings
that will be used to attach the fins to
the scaffold
stay tuned for more as the team prepares
this personal diving watercraft for its
maiden voyage
[Music]
this personal watercraft leaps Dives and
barrel rolls with the waves but it
doesn't capsize
it's been engineered to return to an
upright position in the water
and when it comes to the fun Factor this
diving watercraft leaves other
recreational boats in its wake
to make the diving watercraft's
passenger cabin a worker sprays a gel
coat onto a form and covers it with
fiberglass
a computer-driven router then carves
into marine grade plywood to produce
structural backing for the sides of the
cockpit
a worker slathers adhesive putty onto
the plywood part and applies more
adhesive to the fiberglass cockpit
he presses the plywood to the glued
areas of the cockpit and brushes resin
onto the front of the plywood
after cutting the cockpit section in two
the crew glues the parts to the inside
of the fuselage
the fabricating team applies adhesive
putty to the cone-shaped bumper known as
the sacrificial nose
[Music]
they slide it onto the front of the
fuselage
and then screw the bumper in place
temporarily while the adhesive sets
another worker Sands all the fiberglass
parts of the watercraft to remove bumps
and blemishes this piece is the engine
hatch
[Music]
bolts the aluminum scaffold to the floor
of the fuselage this is a test fit to
confirm that the dimensions are exactly
right
[Music]
as they install the scaffold they use
dummy Wing shafts to correctly position
it within the vessel
they confirm that the dimensions are
right and that the scaffold sits Plumb
to the base of the watercraft
and inserts the hatch frame in the rim
around the cockpit
they'll bind the frame in place later
with a liquid plastic and adhesive putty
after priming the sanded surface of the
watercraft team members lower the 300
horsepower engine into the hatch
this is a dry fit to confirm everything
lines up correctly
they'll eventually remove the engine for
the final paint and artwork
[Music]
as the dry fit continues they connect
the air tubes to the snorkel fins that
deliver air to the engine
foreign
hatch has by now also been primed and
they fitted to the diving watercraft's
main body
the crew verifies that the hatch sits
flush with the rest of the fuselage
[Music]
a worker installs the exhaust Outlet
into the hole at the rear of the
watercraft
crew member slide elevator fins into
bushings at the back
these fins will control the pitch axis
of the watercraft
next they installed the jet propulsion
system
back to the cockpit the crew bolts the
control pedals to the floor and run
cables to the jet propulsion unit the
elevator fins and the steering system
[Music]
they reinstall the dive fin scaffold
which has been powder coated in a yellow
color
connects the die fins to the scaffold
they situate the control panel just
above the control pedals
[Music]
run a metal linkage from the dive fins
to a control stick
foreign
they then test the control stick and
confirm it moves the dive planes easily
and correctly
bucket seats made of lightweight carbon
fiber minimize the load for added speed
they tuck a rubber gasket into the
framework for the clear canopy that will
surround the occupants
they add a bead of sealant where the
gasket mates to the window frame
[Music]
The Vessel canopy is made of thick
aircraft grade acrylic
it's been tinted to repel the sun's rays
and keep the temperature cooler in the
cockpit